thomas bonjour alors vous suivez pour
nous la séance à l'assemblée
que faut-il retenir on a assisté d'abord
aux prises de paroles de membres du
gouvernement c'est nicole belloubet la
garde des sceaux qui a ouvert le bal en
n'exposant le cadre juridique autour de
cette application stop&go vidal a
rappelé par exemple qu'il n'y avait pas
de système de géolocalisation que c'est
la technologie bluetooth qui serait
utilisé qu'il n'y aurait pas non plus de
fichage des personnes qui utilisent
cette application est que l'a rappelé
que c'était sur la base du volontariat
que les français seraient amenés à
télécharger l'application stop qu'ovide
elle a également rappelé un point
important que le téléchargement de cette
application stop covin ne saurait
accorder aucun droit et aucun avantage
aux personnes donc qui téléchargent
cette application toutes les garanties
ont été prises pour respecter la vie
privée des français a par ailleurs
déclaré nicole belloubet et puis c'est
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
qui s'est exprimé il a expliqué qu'il
fallait contrôler par tous les moyens
possibles la résurgence de l'épidémie
et lorsqu'il a exposé les arguments en
faveur donc de cette application stop
comme il a été quelque peu bousculée par
certains députés de l'assemblée je
propose d'écouter cet extrait mais au
nom de quoi j'empêcherai tel ou tel
député telle ou telle personne de
disposer de cet outil de protection vous
poser des questions
vous posez des questions qui sont
totalement légitime sur le plan éthique
est ce que est ce que cette application
est éthique est ce qu'elle est
liberticide comme en temps sur les bancs
n'avait liberticide de dire privative de
liberté en mon sens je considère qu
empêcher quelqu'un se doter d'un outil
qui permet de se protéger
ça c'est sans doute liberticide
ça c'est hors de question
moi je vais vous dire je veux avoir la
liberté je veux avoir la liberté demain
de télécharger ou de ne pas télécharger
d'application pouvoir me protéger je
veux avoir la liberté de choisir dans
une semaine de l'enlever si je n'en veux
plus je veux avoir la liberté de pouvoir
être au courant avant qu'on m'appelle
que je suis potable potentiellement cas
contacts et je veux avoir la liberté de
protéger encore des battes éternellement
et nous sommes là pour ça pas
éternellement mais en débattre et puis
c'est cédric au secrétaire d'état chargé
du numérique qui a pris la parole pour
exposer les conditions d'utilisation de
cette application
stop au vide il a également rappelé que
c'est une application française qui
n'avait pas de lien avec apple et google
mais cela n'a vraisemblablement pas
convaincu tout le monde dans l'hémicycle
puisqu'à la suite des trois membres du
gouvernement c'est jean luc mélenchon
qui a pris la parole
les contre cette application il a exposé
un certain nombre d'arguments que nous
vous exposerons à dans une édition
ultérieure mais ce n'est évidemment pas
le seul député qui n'est pas favorable à
l'utilisation de cette application n'a
pu rencontrer tout à l'heure philippe
gosselin qui est député les républicains
de la manche c'est au micro cynthia
lauvergeon il nous explique pourquoi lui
non plus ne votera pas cette la mise en
place de cette application stop&go vite
j'ai pas de problème particulier avec
edouard philippe ou emmanuel macron je
refais pas des dictateurs en puissance
soyons très clairs et demain de
démocratie elles sont fragiles qui peut
nous assurer que des mains - amis de
l'état de droit de la démocratie ne
s'empare pas de ce que nous aurions créé
avec ce précédent pour la santé qui
paraît légitime
on a tous peur donc on a tous envie de
se dire ali ben oui il faut y aller
c'est possible techniquement
technologiquement allons-y allons-y les
scientifiques le disent ok mais
puisqu'on a déjà des outils en nombre
important que l'état le gouvernement
peut déjà travailler réellement et bien
arrêtons la faisons déjà avec les outils
qui sont en notre possession et le cas
échéant tirons-en les bilans et le
moment venu peut-être faudra-t-il
rajouter autre chose mais pour le moment
il me semble que tout est en ordre
et si on veut continuer à pouvoir le
dire comme on le fait ici en toute
sérénité bien il faut savoir dire stop
vous l'aurez compris des doutes sur la
pertinence de l'utilisation d'une telle
application doute aussi sur l'aspect
sécurité autour d'un tel dispositif et
doute enfin sur l'efficacité de
l'application stop&go vite pour
réellement combattre l'expansion de
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 en france les
débats s'annoncent donc animé dans
l'hémicycle tout au long de cet après
midi les différents représentants des
groupes politiques sont actuellement en
train de prendre la parole il ya donc un
débat avec les membres du gouvernement
présents et puis ce soir à 21h30 c'est
au sénat que cette question de
l'application stop qu'ovide sera
discutée merci beaucoup thomas pour
toutes ces précisions vous retrouve bien
entendu dans nos prochaines éditions
thomas bonnin en direct depuis
l'assemblée nationale